Tim pool came out with a cover of
together again the famed hit by Smoky
Mike and the god king and the song Hit
number one on the iTunes chart which is
where you should go right now to
download it now there's a whole
backstory to Smokey Mike and the god
king which you can hear in Tim's teaser
for the song the year is 1967 and
something incredible happens to music
Smoky Mike and the god king unveiled
their hit song together again the song
was massive charting in both 1967 and
1968 and spent 87 weeks at number
one needless to say America was hooked
and a legacy was born a legacy that
continues to this
day what inspired you to bring a song of
this magnitude into the world I think
it's no secret that our band was
effectively done but I was I was hoping
there was some way we could turn things
around working with my mentor Phil
leonti I asked him is there is there is
there something we can do that's not
been done that'll be big and and he
pointed out with all these greats like
the Beatles with Zeppelin you know and
Smoky Mike and the god king there are a
lot of opportunities for modern versions
that have not been done properly now a
lot of people have covered Zeppelin of
course but no one's done a good modern
version of together again and he was
right and I think that's when we
realized if we get this we get this
right it could be
huge could be huge now the backstory to
that backstory is a couple years ago
Jeremy and I played our song to to a
soldout crowd at the
[Music]
Ryman stronger with you I'm gr stronger
with
you the de best lows the lowest high the
blackest days The Bluest
night in no storm we cannot weather my
friend if we only come together
again so you got the backstory and the
backstory of the backstory but there's
actually a backstory to the backstory of
the backstory and that backstory is what
is politically relevant the story is
that Jeremy and I wanted to cover Happy
Together by The Turtles for that show we
thought it would be funny but since it
was being videotaped we needed to secure
the rights to the song which is usually
just a perun request immediately granted
for a minor fee unless it's
conservatives who are the ones who want
to cover the music in which case the
request gets shut down we were shocked
we talked to friends in the music
industry one extremely successful
songwriter in particular was shocked he
said he'd never heard of such a request
being rejected so we called the company
that holds the rights and we tried to
clear it up they said no we offered more
money they said no we offered even more
money no finally Jeremy who will pay any
price for a joke offered them 100
$150,000 150 Grand just for the
performance rights one time to this old
song and we were told that there is no
amount of money we could offer that
would get us the rights so we had no
other choice but to write a song
ourselves which is how the original
together again was born which is how Tim
pool's cover of together again was born
which is an excellent cover by the way
I've been alone for so long this time
I'm going stronger with
you I've been long so long this time
growing stronger with
you keep it low lowest SI blackest days
and bluest nights ain't no storm we can
ra my friend if we just come together
again
great song worth buying in its own right
but especially worth buying when you
remember that you can stick it to lib
music Executives who hate us for the low
price of only 67 cents or whatever the I
don't know what a song costs to download
on iTunes but for that low price you can
get it so please if you love great music
if you love owning the libs if you are
not that attached to the change in your
pocket please head on over to iTunes or
Amazon music to download Together Again
by Tim Po by Michael
and Jeremy boring Smoky mic and the god
king
today